Today we will be showing you how to enable
to Google Cloud Debugger on Google compute
engine the debugger is enabled by
default for App Engine and standard
manage VM images for Java the debugger
provides insight without requiring you
to make any changes to your code. with
each snapshot it because possible to
view the call stack and variables of
your application
all without stopping or slowing down.
All new projects have these API enables by
default. Older projects may need them
enabled. Connect with the cloud source
repository using Gcloud beta source repos
clone default and the name of
your directory in this case sparky. Copy
the files to the new directory. And add
the debugger agent to the startup script.
First download the latest version the
bootstrap script for cloud storage and
make it executable. Next, run the
bootstrap script giving it a relative
path to the application class files and
assigning the return java command line
arguments to the environment variable.
lastly, we modify the java command line
to run the application – it's that simple
commit and push your source code to the
cloud source repository
and tell the debugger about source
context so that the Debugger can display
the correct version of your deployed
application. Here we use GCloud preview
app gen-repo-info-file to output the source
context JSON to the class directory
typically you'll do this during mavens
process resource phase. Build the project,
and deploy it
grab the IP address. Make sure works.
Navigate to source > debug and to your
source file.
So we can take a snapshot by clicking in
the gutter of line we wish to investigate.
Now wait for an incoming requests that
causes the line to trigger the gathering
of the snapshot. That was fast! Look at the results
note that the app wasn't blocked and is
still running and handling incoming
traffic at full speed.
you can also look at the call stack.
We've shown you how to enable and use
the debugger. For more information
take a look at the documentation. We
provide support on Stack Overflow and
the source of the examples on GitHub.